one thing i love about american cons is
that they have events going on i
remember going to my first british con
and you go there to drink half of my
panels were in a bar area so while
you're doing your panel people are
lining up to get beer and stuff i don't
even know what the biggest anime
convention in the uk is
wow
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm with the boys once again you know
how it is joey and gar and of course we
have a guest today caisson
introduce yourself
hello thank you for having me today i am
caisson the delinquent oh okay
oh oh
[Music]
oh you've been really polite so far
no no i haven't yeah all right i mean
look at that look at the way she's
sitting yeah she look at the way she's
posing she's gonna be doing that for the
entire podcast what i can poop here any
time you know
[Music]
only two people can sit like this l and
caisson
i think you're the first guest who's
ever brought up poop before we have
normally we have to apologize whenever
we bring up poop is our thing we usually
start with we normally we've made a pact
not to bring it up because we bring it
up too often yeah
delinquent i am see
just completely disregard the golden
rule of trash taste which just don't
bring up poop drive from the get-go but
i'm sure many are wondering caisson why
are you here in your v tuber form and
not your your human form
that's true that's true why not because
people love me in this form more all
right all right
then i love you in the other four i'm
sure i'm sure i love you in the office
but um
yeah um but i kind of feel comfortable
in this form
because i don't have to put my makeup on
you know that that is something that i
find very envious with every vtuber that
you just you just turn on the camera you
don't need to like give a [ __ ] about how
you look yeah yeah i usually don't give
a [ __ ]
i
do morning streams i wake up i got hit
by a truck and i'm i'm live and
everyone's like connor you look dead
every stream without fail sounds like
connie look tired like no [ __ ] that's
what happens when you wake up
it's like it could be 3 p.m and i still
look like [ __ ] i just don't care anymore
i just permanently have eye bags so you
can tell whenever i'm recording
something late at night or early in the
morning because i always always without
fail get the comments of oh have you
been sleeping enough
i was like oh thanks mum no i've been
sleeping enough don't worry about it oh
my general practitioner here uh it seems
like god's not getting enough sleep oh
my god
oh my god wait do you prefer so do you
prefer actually doing v tuber streams or
how can i say 3d streaming irl streams
because you've done a lot of
irl live action whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it before right
i call it a 3d high polygon
all right all right
unreal
before we get into it do you want to
explain to the viewers what you do and
what you do for streaming and everything
like that yes oh yeah um
um i'm uh i'm a delinquent v tuber um i
debuted on
october 16th so i'm kind of
uh
a new a new one
yeah
but i've been streaming for um i've been
doing this for like um three years and
five years ago i started um
filming videos of me playing games and
and then after
that
oh
um i
thought i would like
let's do the youtuber stuff because i'm
i'm tired of
putting makeup on myself
like you're tired of the high polygons
yeah
because you've done a lot of cosplay
stuff right you did a lot of cosplay
streams right
stuff but that's like the antithesis of
putting on makeup
like you put a lot of makeup on yeah
yeah makeup's like step one right yeah
yeah and then it's like 20 steps after
that yeah yeah how much prep do you have
to do for a cosplay stream whenever
you're cosplaying someone first of all
um i make all my cosplay costumes oh wow
from scratch really yeah i'm good at
showing
so i'm i make it myself so
step zero i have to
stop it
wow make it so you don't just buy
trying to find an adult minecraft steve
costume it's very difficult
i have i have a shirt and a pair of
pants that is the exact same coloration
i want like the blocks right i've been
trying to find a minecraft steve costume
and it's been very difficult because
everyone i've i've purchased or seen is
for the ages of six to twelve
now i'm thinking one so i ended up just
buying the six to twelve one and five
okay i'll just i'll make it work
squeezing i'll just i'll just rip that
thing off this big make it for you yeah
you should keep your case on
can i can i do that maybe i'll maybe
i'll do that i don't know what your
rates are it's probably very expensive
actually i didn't know you made your own
cosplays how long does it take to make
um
if i concentrate maybe for like three
days if you use a hundred percent that's
the biggest percent of my brain power
and concentrate well usually i can't do
that so it takes about like two
weeks that yeah that sounds real because
like i've seen some of your cosplay
streams in the past yeah and like i
remember the you did one for bayonetta
yeah the banana yeah the banana i see
clips everywhere yeah yeah and i'm like
and i'm like how the hell did you make
that
by yourself
because that's better than like some
like professional band at the cosplays
that i've seen oh thank you was that
like the longest one you did what's the
longest one you that took you maybe
bayonetta because her hair yeah
her hair i had to
um buy like um three wigs three
wigs and like um mess it up and like on
did you see did you see that on the
screen yeah yeah yeah yeah your head
that like hair band thing that like
defies physics it's actually like built
actually spongebob's home that's been
relocated
it's so hard i had to throw away like
three wigs i messed up a lot of weeks
so much money and time
i can see why you do this now
yeah now
you've had like uh you know a very uh
long and famous career doing this this
stuff and it's really impressive one
thing that i
am
kind of
weirdly impressed by because this is one
thing that i find that people really
struggle to do
is that you have mainly uh is it correct
instead of a japanese audience mainly
yeah but you also have an english
following
yeah and it's normally really hard for
creators to balance
two different languages yeah yeah in
fact because like a lot of the platforms
just don't want you to speak both
languages yeah because they want to know
okay you speak english we're
recommending you to english speakers you
speak japanese only japanese speakers
are getting it no how do you find
balancing that like because you know
it's way beyond my my ability
i'm figuring it out to be honest um
like for
the japanese viewers they
um
they don't like me speaking mostly in
english because
obviously they wanna
yeah yeah
and um well but i mostly
my viewers are mostly japanese and i
mostly do
um the streams on in japanese
so
sorry what gave you the idea to try and
branch out to a more international
audience that's that's what i'm curious
about or was it just your you had a
language you know skill set and you just
wanted to flex it kind of
um
i don't know yeah maybe
maybe yeah
i guess it's like if you or is it dumb
luck
oh you're just like i'm just gonna give
it a go see if it works kind of thing
you just wing it
like that
i'm like um
yeah let's try it and if it works out
good like i'm that kind of person and
there you go
think and like strategize i just do it
it's just a genius what can i say
yeah i'm just a genius delinquent yeah
i'm envious of you being able to speak
great japanese and english i'm
jerry's also
yeah yeah but the thing is i haven't
been able to diversify my audience as
much as
i feel have you tried to like capture a
japanese audience at all and are you
even interested in
i just i'm personally just not really
interested in it just because it's like
i don't know it's just because i feel
it's just so
different in terms of like content and
stuff like that like if it's kind of
like you know like what kson does where
it's like whole variety stuff right like
where you can just basically do whatever
the hell you want yeah then it's a
little bit easier to try and branch out
right but i don't know it's also a lot
of effort to do both yeah what i mean i
don't know if this is correct right i
could be completely wrong i've heard
some stories about people who have
audiences both like some youtubers uh
they subtitle their stuff in japanese
yeah and they have quite a decent
japanese following uh
the main the main thing i've been told
is that japanese people have no chill
online uh that's the one thing
one criticism that i've heard a lot it's
it's it's scary at least that's from
from an english perspective yeah i don't
know is it what is it like having the
two different types of audiences do you
notice a difference between them both
like distinctly other than the language
other than the language um
well
well
i don't know japanese people
like well it's just from my perspective
okay
of course it's illegal it's all opinions
all your opinions i just said they had
no chill i think i'm in trouble probably
um japanese people mostly um don't want
to see my
3d high polygon stuff right right it's
just it's not like they don't love me as
in that style it's like um
they could
i don't know relate more to the anime
yeah
i i don't know i
that's the part i don't understand much
about yeah yeah because you're the same
person right yeah yeah it's just one's
2d and one's a 3d polygon playing a
character or anything like at all are
you
well i i am a delinquent
i'm not playing a character i'm just
delinquent yeah i was born delinquent um
um and what was i talking about
i guess it kind of makes sense right
because you know otherwise if if the
japanese audience didn't have this like
infatuation with these 2d streamers then
v tubing wouldn't really be a thing in
the first place i feel
that's
it's weird like that infatuation had to
come from somewhere right yeah and like
japan is already like especially japan's
like otaku culture is already so
obsessed with like
you know the whole 2d thing i mean i got
the western brain i don't know that's
like a disease i got western
i got western
to give possible reasons such a strange
concept because like my parents like
have no like don't understand the whole
v tubing thing at all but they're like
but they're always so curious being like
why is it that people like this and it's
so hard to explain to them why it's like
they'll never understand right
yeah but like even if i like you know
brought up the whole debate of like you
know japanese people love 2d [ __ ] and
when you put a real person into it then
it becomes more interactive it's it's
they'll be like i still why not just
show the real face and i'm like valid
argument parents
well that's not how it works i mean i
work like that yeah my parents don't
understand anime period so trying to
explain youtubers to them it's just like
a whole another level it's like anime
but real focus my parents haven't asked
me yet luckily
i i had this the other i had this the
other day when i went back home to
england and i had to explain to like my
family members like what vtubers was
right and there was just like
so many
levels i had to explain to even like
come close to like introducing the idea
of youtube yeah yeah yeah because they
didn't know what streamers how streamers
made money they didn't know what
youtubers would so i need to i needed to
like basically explain the internet
before i could even like start
explaining what vg was uh
iron mouse told me a really [ __ ]
funny story that her mom her mum so her
mom is like doesn't understand it either
right yeah and uh because because mouse
is like really sick and and you know
can't leave her house and uh can't do
anything really and um
her mom thought that everyone who was a
v tuber was also in the same
was sick and there's just something so
wholesome about that that i thought oh
i don't know why that just like warmed
my heart in a weird way where your mom
was like is everyone the same
no mom
but thanks for asking it's a nice sandal
yeah that was really awesome how did you
explain to your parents when you started
getting into v tubing um i didn't
explain to them
what did you tell them
they know now right
now but
they will never understand so i just
didn't
and my daddy
um
still doesn't understand anything about
what i do i think does he does he keep
asking you to get like a normal job
um no he didn't do that but um
he like
what the [ __ ] is like
v tubing and why does everyone pay money
to you
know a solid argument
um
see they're they're on step two of
parent step one step one is the the
period where they're like you should you
should go get a real job yeah and then
step and then step two is where they've
just given up on that they just start to
question what you do yeah
cause like i remember when i first quit
to do youtube and patreon was like my
main form of revenue my parents on my
car yeah and then i had to explain to my
parents what patreon was and why why
that was basically my monthly salary
yeah so i'm just like yeah so just
people pay me to uh be me and uh do
things that i did already and they're
like no but what are they paying you for
like um
to just to be me and they're like no no
no but what are you selling to them like
i'm not saying well
i feel like you're explaining it pretty
badly yeah just like just existing yeah
it's like welfare really but just uh
specific for me
i mean isn't that just what youtube ad
revenue is welfare for youtube yeah
we're all fair for youtube a bit too
generous i think the world fairs
oh my god
very generous welfare
yeah
well when you're starting off it's like
welfare right yeah yeah so going back to
the language thing are you surprised how
much of a potential there was in an
international audience because v tubing
until like the last few years was very
much a japanese thing it was a japanese
idea and i think like
a lot of your like a lot of your content
made it so that it was more accessible
to people in the west so were you
surprised at all with like the rise of
youtubing just globally i was really
surprised i thought
like um
just like my daddy had some allergies
about these internet v tubing things
it was the same for those um
western uh viewers to have like um this
anime
well
anime avatar avatar thing talking to you
like that maybe
it will like feel weird but i thought it
was really
fun thing and i just wanted to introduce
to them there's something like this and
it's really fun if you don't like it
it's fine but just
just take a peek at it
all right
it's kind of crazy how much it blew up
in
the west i guess really yeah
almost overnight it feels like it blew
up was it was it overwhelming at the
time of course it was [ __ ]
i thought it was overwhelming when it
was happening in the japanese audience
as well yeah true true
like why are all these english people
coming in what the [ __ ] it's like you
only have to worry about you know one
small island nation worrying about it
and now you have the entire world
looking at you
yeah scary i mean it's kind of like
anime itself right where a lot of it was
originally just you know everyone
thought that only japan cared about
anime yeah and now it's getting to a
point where it's just becoming the
mainstream cool thing for all your kids
to be watching anime and like you're
bullied now for not watching anime and
now yeah like i i remember my kids have
it easy
yeah like i remember have like i had
like a monthly like discord hangouts
where um some of the members who are in
my discord group have been like watching
me for like
like seven to ten years and it's like
that that already blows my mind but
every so often we uh get someone new
into the group and normally you know
everyone introduced myself by saying
their favorite anime and you know saying
you know their wife or husbando and like
in the past few years it used to always
be you know anime waifu or you know
anime has bandos yeah but now every
every time someone new comes in it's
like always v tubers now
it's their oshie's now yeah all right
yeah there's v tubers uh a lot of them
getting figures a lot of them getting
androids
which is pretty crazy right like that's
i think if you'd have said that like two
years ago everyone would be like no well
i mean i think i right yeah i was like
when kizna i started blowing up and she
got like her own
figure and stuff like that yes
i was like i was like whoa what the [ __ ]
this is so weird they're like figures
yeah like when the figures came out was
nuts but now it's just like pretty
normal yeah super normal yeah
when's your when's your fear coming okay
so
eventually you're the newcomer as a
viewer you can sell two things
and figure out why nfg
[Music]
i was wondering where you're going
i was like figuring nendoroids
i was like figuring super chat
we haven't thankfully we haven't gotten
to that point i don't think yet but uh
because you could sell there is you
could sell yourself right as an nft
stop stop is that what is that what
they're doing we like we don't need we
don't need this idea to be you know
i i i just kind of clock out whenever i
see the nft now i just stopped looking i
don't read any article i don't want to
look at it just just yeah you're the one
that keeps bringing it up on the show
okay one more one more thing before i
stop talking about nft have you seen the
clip of keanu laughing at nfts
no it's so good there's this clip where
this guy talks to keanu reeves about
nfts and he just starts giggling
you mentioned something about
replicating it
it's such a good reaction
just the idea of like gotcha nft is just
like that that scares me so much don't
tell them that girl yeah you just gave
him an idea now
every gaijin company is like all i'm
saying is garcia companies don't make
enough money
i think they're making it i think they
that was a sarcastic joke right there
just just just so just so that was like
s
got into [ __ ] fate and their
quarterly revenue went out yeah exactly
are you do you play any gatches or any
of those games
[Music]
what's your addiction if you have one
that he saw what are you my addiction
yeah let me think other than adidas okay
that's not an addiction that's a
lifestyle that's like a strip that's
true i need a squat
see my my costume has adidas lines in it
does it really oh oh [ __ ] yeah look look
oh yeah oh yeah yeah it's um
i can't say that sure what's your guilty
your passion then what are you uh are
you any games or anything that you're
super addicted to super addicted to let
me think this is not gotcha it's a win
streaming
yeah i'm addicted to streaming of course
right i'm a full-time streamer so yes
but um
right now i'm addicted to far cry
okay which one the new one yeah
um i'm right now i'm playing far cry 5.
oh are you going through them all yeah
yeah oh okay okay i heard they get like
worse and worse as they go on
i heard like
i've only played
three i think
yeah was that the good one
three is the good one i enjoyed it i
enjoy playing three
what's your favorite far cry so far um
i've only played five i just started i
just started oh oh okay oh oh you've
only played far cry 5. yeah
she's already involved i thought she's
played like [ __ ] right once again yeah
yeah
all right i've been lied to god damn
i have fun it's far cry 5 the good one
or the i i i i
i i didn't play football i don't think
metacritic likes it but you know is that
the one with like the rednecks oh no i i
just i just i just know the one with
like gus that's the new one six okay so
that's that's frame that's frank he's
the meme of we are not the same i can't
i can't oh that guy yeah yeah
have you ever seen breaking bad yet have
you no okay do
so you've been playing far cry and then
you also we played minecraft
oh yeah i have my own server i just
started playing with my friends well
thank you for telling me on my server um
yeah
sorry for that
like top 10 anime between that happens i
was invisible to be fair i will you know
give you the benefit of the doubt
and then you went and killed yourself
anyway like two minutes later so it was
okay i think it was all right i think i
think it was revenge was well served
yeah by yourself
but uh
minecraft is pretty fun i enjoy
minecraft joey's a minecraft expert no
i'm not he is he's an expert i'm not
he's an expert i just tried to get you
into it he's an expert so i opened the
door for you so you've never played
minecraft before you mostly slide
streaming minecraft no yeah yeah yeah i
still i really want to get into it the
first time you played minecraft was with
me yeah the old studio oh yeah are you
liking my how many times you played
minecraft now how many
um i just started um i'm just a beginner
i don't know it's really overwhelming
right yeah there's so much to do
if it is fun or not it depends what
you'd like to do luckily minecraft is
varied so you can do what you want now i
on the server on the vshojo server which
i played on yeah uh they were just all
building things i didn't want to build
things
yeah i wanted i wanted to go and like do
the raids because there's like i want to
do a i want to have a goal that's that's
the biggest yeah well there's like
there's like bosses and raids in the in
this modded one yeah so i wanted to just
go and explore and kill things and level
up that's a good thing about minecraft
you can do anything you can do whatever
you want man your imagination is the
limit you can code in minecraft can you
actually yeah there's redstone and you
can code with it yeah there's a dude who
made a fully functioning computer in
minecraft using redstone yeah yeah they
made pokemon as well
they programmed pokemon into the game
they made a working cell phone drink but
i think it was a promotion with um att
or something something like that yeah at
least one of their phones works because
normally that's where they're like they
they
they code i think it's not like they
coded it into the game so that when you
put on a webcam right the blocks
according to the webcam like pixels
but it's all pretty it's a very powerful
game yeah it's really cool it's
something like that it's it's pretty fun
when you get into it and you start to
understand a bit more about the game it
gets more fun i think you'll enjoy
yeah and then if you get bored just go
creative mode and just do whatever the
[ __ ] you want it's a camera thing with
with mod does that work with much
[Music]
i don't know if that's a publicly
available mod it might have been like a
it might have been a one-off thing yeah
i think was it captain sparkles
something like that yeah it's one of the
big minecraft youtubers i feel sad that
i missed the minecraft boom in some ways
it'll come back i mean it's kind of
booming it never stops
it just kind of does this right now it
had like we missed
now we're booming with content before it
used to be just songs and [ __ ] and that
was so funny those songs all the
animations yeah yeah i love those
terrible i mean i mean i feel like every
time it dies it comes back
it comes back even stronger and yeah
like i i feel like goku yeah
oh my [ __ ] god joey
all right i filled my anime quarter for
the episode uh let's move on joey's
mentioned an anime
proving like that i am the anime man
yeah where you know every song just come
back you're all right
yeah are you are you a big anime fan um
yeah i think i am i think you think you
are um
he's like ascended now
the title alone scares people exactly
what kind of anime do you like what are
you into um i i grew up with dragon ball
of course i love goku um
i can do gohan's voice oh really yeah
barely dead gohan
so to explain this is the japanese voice
again
how did you get this because
sounds very different
what made you want to learn this skill
i didn't learn it um some viewer told me
that i sound like i'm barely dead go
ahead
just go for it i mean yeah you're good
at it that sounds pretty smart
i'm a pro at barely dead go handcuff you
almost kind of sound like barely dead
goku as well oh yeah
goku and the japanese dub do sound very
very similar yeah i mean they are
farther i don't know i don't know it
makes sense i don't know the difference
what of gohan and goku gohan's like
do you hear the difference it's a very
shuttle difference they're only dragon
ball fans
the warper needs to tell you the
difference corporate needs to find a
difference between these two sounds
between dying gohan and dying
let's just rewind back a bit you said
you don't know dragon ball no what
what wait what do you mean have you ever
watched it already i've never watched it
or read it played it so you only know it
through osmosis yeah i know that they do
they are can i hand my
oh
heart
god
i think i think my dad might know more
about dragon ball than you do i know the
spirit bomb yeah that's i know the
hadroken architecture
sure you can right that's
i've never felt such a bigger generation
gap than than now almost okay
so like
so like how many of like the side
characters and like their laws do you
know or anything like that you know
vegeta right i know vegeta i know
piccolo do you know who vegeta marries
bulma yeah okay that's just from like
people on twitter like role playing it
and i'm like i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this and do you know what their kid's
name is
trunks i know trunks yeah i didn't know
that was his kid yeah i know trunks
because the guy who wanted to look like
trunks and he like dresses up and i saw
that video the guy like 70k on himself
yeah he looks like have you seen this
video it's a guy who wants to look like
trunks in the us i think yeah and then
he like he does look like trunks to be
fair but to be fair like he like plastic
surgery yeah so yeah he gets like
plastic surgery and he also like colors
his hair purple it's really bizarre but
he's also like jack-jack yeah i mean
whatever makes you happy yeah so he like
looks like a real-life trunks it's
pretty cool i mean he seems like he's
killing it yeah
as long as you're not hurting anyone as
long as you're happy imagine boo
oh yeah
that would have been really embarrassing
if i got that wrong um do you know the
villain that comes before martian um yes
um
i'm just realizing every [ __ ] dragon
ball reference i've made during the last
two years you've just smiled no no no no
no no no no no it's not an entirely no
no our friendship is based on your life
goku
listen drip goku has nothing to do with
cocaine is probably like oh yeah i love
that episode where he puts on the
supreme
i love him i love it when he puts on the
supreme jacket
episode ever
are you aware of this meme the the drip
goku meme oh yeah okay
i actually have the jacket i didn't
bring it with me today though
unfortunately i saw it on twitter oh
yeah i should have brought it with you
you could have been dressed i i wanted
to drift oh my god
uh i know the villain name i know him
the the one that looks like a budget
mewtwo um
a freezer that's it that's it frieza
he looks like a bunch of mewtwo
i'm pretty sure frieza came before me
which one's frieza fr freezer is budget
mewtwo
okay right but frieza definitely came
before mewtwo
so mewtwo is the budget frieza oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up see see i i understand
dragon ball references because i've been
in the otaku animation yeah where i
understand dragon ball reference and i'm
like
you can't like name like any story
portion or anything like that sometimes
i'll make a joke being like oh my god
this is so long it's like a dragon ball
fights
people will be like that's so real
connor
vegeta and goku were fighting for like
20 episodes that that did happen yeah
exactly right c yeah it's easy enough to
figure out what dragon ball fans like to
be fair
that's probably one of the shorter
fights it's like if you if you let me go
in the zoo i'm sure i could fit in with
the monkeys after 20 minutes of watching
oh yeah it's like that
why do you use that
i just i'm sorry i just wanted to take a
jabber dragonball just to assimilate
that's one of those
i thought you were taking a jabba
getting off dragon ball though is there
any other animes that you like as well
naruto of course
so you love fortnite
yes and i love it i think what happened
is he saw where boruto was going and
he's just like i've lost all hope with
this franchise and i have to revive
himself hey to be fair watching him do
like the signs i don't know what they're
called uh the jutsus the jutsus and then
just pull out a gun there's something
really funny about that i think i think
we call that russian gun
yeah
just did the hand thing and whipped out
an ak and it's like what the [ __ ] and
then did a fortnight yeah
it's like
a fever dream the first time i watched
that i think you were seeing sasuke do
the fortnite dance that just really like
killed my [ __ ] childhood that that's
the it wasn't the gun it was the
fortnight dance and i'm just like
yeah it's just kakashi flossing because
it's only one amount of time before we
get tanjiro doing it and i'm just like
this is this this is what itachi died
for this is just just like [ __ ]
sasuke doing the fortnite dance i'm just
what are the animes you're into it seems
like you're into like the classics it's
a classic yeah i mean the classic ones
and um of course um
and that's how you fit it in japan i
i've realized if i want to fit in and
with any japanese person
yeah i love kimono
it's like himetsu one piece and jojo if
you say those yeah more so kimatsu and
one piece i'd say jojo sometimes people
are like what's that yeah jojo is like a
specific demographic whereas kimetz is
just everyone every single even if
they're like 80 90 years old they they
know comments and they've watched it
yeah and jiu jitsu weirdly now actually
yeah did you see kaisen is and uh
weirdly so yeah did you like jesus
christ i loved it i thought it was so
good i thought it was like just okay i
don't know oh my god here it is with
joey
joey's like i don't know i'm too popular
it's not even that it's like i thought
um i'm on joey's side with it um
it was like i i thought it had
everything that i thought i was going to
like but then the end result was just
kind of like what underwhelming i don't
know
where before we before we start
comparing what did you think of demon
slayer then i thought the message was
good by the way do you think it's on the
same level i think i think jimenez is
better than jesus kaisen personally i'm
holding my title
do you agree yeah what did you think was
not good about jiu jitsu it's too
complicated
oh it wasn't even though
what was your video i understood
everything tell me your argument i don't
know it's just it just kind of had every
trope that we've already seen
just demonstrate that's literally yeah
yeah i felt like you did the tropes the
best that's what made it stand out is
that it took the tropes and they did
some other things that were interesting
as well and it just did it better i'm
not saying it was a bad shot i enjoyed
the show i just don't think it's as good
as people say it is
i think it's i think it deserves the
hype way more than dean's leg bro
watching jiu jitsu kaisen and then
watching some like my hero academia it's
it's like going from a five yeah so i go
from a five course meal to like a plane
cracker i'll do it
i would watch jutsu over my hero any day
to be honest do you like my academia
um better than jujutsu
oh really see the the difference you
know i really regret inviting you right
now
today
we can't agree on anything i didn't
think i'd get passionate about anime
today because it's because it's trash
taste but i'm getting passionate about
family today
this is like the it's fortnite overrated
conversation
literally this is literally that
conversation like we're talking about
our anime overrate [ __ ] hell i hate
my life did you watch arcane
no i don't know that watch our kids oh
thank god okay really nice so good it's
so good it's so good please watch it
please watch it but we all agree that
one piece is the best right yes i
haven't watched it yes have you ever
watched you watch one piece right you
read it watch it read it watch it
um
i know how far did you get this this is
like when my mom asked me if i studied
sanji joined and that's the end of my
journey
that's like chapter 20.
hell yeah we're on the same page that's
not even the epilogue i mean yeah that's
not even prologue i've read zero
chapters
but you're going to right i am going to
yeah again i've only watched the four
kids uh version that's i'm sorry and
again i think i've mentioned it before
like the the stuff i really tell me when
you start reading it and i will also
like re-read from where i am yeah so
that we can all be up to speed okay i
always get curious do you watch like and
play stuff that your stream basically
recommends because i noticed
working working in the field i guess you
know some of the recommendations some of
the recommendations i get of what to
watch and play basically just come from
my audience
so i'm wondering if is that how you guys
not just to case on but is that how you
guys basically choose what media to
consume nowadays as well
um
but
i i say mostly yes yeah yeah i don't get
any informations from other friends
they're just
they never leave home they don't know
anything they don't watch tv so
are they in prison
for anything like that
i mean i guess you've got to like follow
your audience to some capacity right
because you know you are you are i guess
performing quote unquote too though when
you're on stream so do you get a lot of
free time because we've had uh we've had
previous videos on before she's a
streamer of course she does sometimes
i do nothing
you sounded so happy about that that's
not so sad
otaku dream right yeah just doing
nothing it's doing nothing so do nothing
you know initially with v tubing what
made you want to
go for that was it purely just for the
not wanting to put makeup on or was
there something about it that you kind
of were kind of leaning towards with the
whole v tubing that made you want to go
for it in the first place
i thought um
well i just thought v tubing was cool
right
look like it's it's gonna
make some movement or something like
that something about say money
i felt like a money
yeah money
yeah
did you have like anyone any streamers
that kind of inspired you to start
youtubing in the first place um of
course uh kidzuna
yeah she was so inspiring um
did you guys um watch the the backstreet
boys
that movie of kizuna
singing what what
everybody yeah
are you serious wait what that was the
one that got me into me tubing stuff
really yeah wait so what so what is it
was that wasn't mmd though
yeah
yeah i didn't know if it was v tubing or
m d but i feel it felt like the
animation it's kind of like a v tubing
so the backstreet boys got you into v
tubing um not like that but
that's a good sentence i think
that's like that's like the domino
that's like the domino image right
backstreet
boys forms k-son becomes a v-tuber
the whole v-tubing industry
backstreet boys
yeah yeah
justin timberlake it was like mmd models
of he's not i that sag backstreet
that's now gonna hold on did you just
say i did i just said i say justin
so like before you started streaming on
youtube were you mainly on youtube like
watching stuff on youtube or were you on
like nico nico as well in other japanese
sites
i didn't know much uh about
youtube because um
i didn't watch it i just i just didn't i
didn't find any
content interesting for me yeah now but
um what's the nikon eco community like
because people people a lot of people
who you know obviously can't speak
japanese and especially the
international audience to me it feels
like it's its own very tight-knit
community with its own culture and
everything like that
for me it was like the only platform i
knew
right so so like you're just like the
perception of the internet was just like
niko niko for you right yeah
i feel it was like that though because
like i used to be on nico nico as well
when i was in high school and it's like
it like they have their own memes that
just like never leave niconico so were
you watching nico nico from like high
school
i was watching nico nicole i started
watching when i was in
college
and
[Music]
yeah i think i was in college right i
started because my my dad my parents
never
they never let me play games they were
like um oh
yeah they're like super strange
super strict about it they were like
games make you stupid all right do that
it was kind of apparent
did they let you watch my anime no never
wait wait so what did you do in your
free time as a kid
i was hiding under my bed and reading
dragon ball
the true delinquent
the delinquency started from such a
young age of course because when they
say not to do it you want to do that of
course yeah of course of course
and now look what i'm doing daddy mommy
i'm playing games
i'm playing games and talking about
dragon ball and now i am anime
goes full circle
so you were watching it in college and
then when did you think oh man i kind of
want to join in on this um
when i started working um
one of my colleagues were
like
he talked to me like um how um do you
like games and like he started talking
about games and we became good friends
because i was really interested in games
because i started to make money myself
and i was buying a lot of games that
hell yeah i was i was living by myself
so there was no one to stop me so i was
like buying a lot of games playing it
enjoying it and
my colleague was like um there are like
streamers uh playing games online you
watch it and i got interested in it and
i started watching it
and then and then he said like um
um i
want to stream like them how about we do
it together
yeah he'll suggest it like
let's do the streaming stuff together we
ended up never doing it together
because um he said it he said he
he i don't know he just disappeared
um okay i'll do it myself and i started
um making
movies it was like just
just um recording it and just cutting
the end or something like that it's not
like i mean let's plays yeah the let's
play okay yeah yeah yeah okay all right
and i started like posting it on nico
nico that was my start it was like 2017.
so you had a job before you were doing
this and you were doing the job while
you were posting this stuff as well yeah
am i allowed to ask what you did before
or
um
i was working
let's keep it a secret okay
so i was on that ground
at a job where uh colleagues disappear
the delinquent life has been strong
so how long are you posting let's plays
for then um for
for
like three years oh wow and it was that
with like did it ever pick up or was it
like just not that many viewers
throughout the whole time
um it
my first very first video that i posted
on nico nicole
came viral
like the very first one what did you do
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait so i need to
ask what is viral nico nico because nico
nico on viral
uh it means um like there's a ranking in
nico nicole you guys know nico nico
rankings yeah yeah yeah yeah i like that
one
and
it was like ranking one to five was mine
oh wow it's basically like like uh i
think it's weekly or monthly something
like that right yes
yeah so basically like at the front page
of nico nico usually there's like a
ranking for like the top videos for this
week or the top videos for this month
and then they just have links so that's
like their algorithm what was so special
about this video
like like i imagine i imagine if it's
your first video it's probably bad
[Applause]
i know um the first very first video
that i posted was me
struggling
with japanese but trying to play it in
japanese and the first one i was playing
the game siren you guys know siren oh uh
fatal frame no no
is it no no is it a horror game no it's
a different one right yeah
yeah
it's like fatal frame is it just you
raging at the japanese yeah
i could see why that would do well
actually yeah yeah i can see what that
one there are no
i i think no one did that before so yeah
and you did that for three years
and i just kept growing
i
i wasn't like um
constantly doing that i was like
throwing videos on nico nico and like
do nothing for a half a year just
disappear just disappear yeah
i relate to that that's what i did
yeah that's that's i did what i did for
the first three years i just throw the
video to nico nico and do nothing start
some more
do nothing
so i feel i feel like it's it's pretty
rare on nico nico for there to be like
content creators that constantly produce
because they don't make money right you
don't make money
so people just saw the clout yeah just
people just do it because they want to
make some [ __ ] yeah they're just
passionate they're just passionate in
their content [ __ ] bro could you imagine
that's the biggest crime alive
doing sound for free hell no not in this
economy
honestly like i've seen like sometimes
you see nikon eco content that gets like
you know that gets replaced on youtube
and it's absolutely [ __ ] insane some
of the content some of the edits are
just like
ridiculous yeah
yeah
like seeing some of the like the mad
edits like during the peak of the amv
years where you know you thought there
were some like mad talented amv editors
which there are and then out of nowhere
you just get this like mad like clip
that just got posted from nico nuco and
it was just [ __ ] insane what they
were doing compared to what you know
what what you could see on youtube i
mean you know like all the vocaloid
producers used to upload this [ __ ]
i started from there yeah it all started
from there and they just did it not
because they were making money off of it
just because they were like i made this
song check it out yeah
how do you feel do you imagine
it's quite easy when i was i i started
in university and i did it for fun but
that's because the university haven't
got bills to pay right
government the loans are paying your
bills
exactly you have to spare time as well
right yeah yeah yeah the actual time is
awesome it's fair so when did you like
transfer over to youtube and what made
you transfer over platforms to youtube
in the first place
well the viewers like um
told me that they were like
um it'll be easy to watch it on youtube
then nico nico
they just told me that so okay then i'll
do it on youtube
and it felt like it was more easier for
me to stream on youtube
because to stream on nico nico it's it's
kind of like complicated you have to
put all those put all those softwares in
your pc and it was so complicated for me
and it felt like it was really easy for
me to do it on youtube so i just went to
youtube i think it's also because the
nikon ecosystem just hasn't changed
at all everything looks like it's like
on live leak on nikon yeah yeah the
quality is like so you don't want to
know it okay yeah you don't want to know
what that is
i remember i remember before like i
would you know i'd heard about nico nico
as an anime fan you'd hear about this
mythical website that all the japanese
people use called
and i just you know i remember trying to
watch some videos on it and even just
like watching a video you know with
youtube or basically any like western's
video hosting website all you need to do
is just go on the site search up a video
click on the video and you can watch the
video yeah so i remember clicking on
some nikon eco links and uh you have to
like sign up to a special account just
to watch videos or something like that
yeah you if you don't have an account on
nikon you can't watch anything yeah
yeah
and then i i remember i like i couldn't
understand what all this like text
flying across the screen
i was just like what is this this is
ruining my viewing experience it's like
i can't see anything this is blocking
the content
how are you how are people watching this
right now yeah whenever you watch like
speed running summoning salt videos
whenever they're runners from japan yeah
yeah
you can just see all the comments yeah
yeah all the things flying across the
screen exactly exactly oh my god i
remember
one time i can't yeah i think it was on
nikonuko where one of the madoka
episodes got streamed on nico nico
and i didn't know i didn't know how to
like i didn't know how to figure out how
to just like turn off the comments yeah
um so basically whenever yeah whenever
whenever anyone quoted something big
whenever madoka would say a line you'd
see like a line of comments just like
quoting the episode before she said it
right
so it was literally like you know that
what that movie experience where you're
sitting next to someone who's quoting
the entire vlog
it was just like that but online
basically today's episode is sponsored
by honey we'll shop online and we've all
seen that promo code feel torn us at the
checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past gentleman honey's the free
browser extension that scales the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your card honey
sports over 30 000 stores online they
range from having tech and gaming
products to popular fashion brands and
even food delivery all right guys here's
how it works all right imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
when you're at the checkout the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for all the
coupons you can find for that site and
if honey finds a working coupon your
watch as the prices drop
i recently spent a lot of money on
plushies over a hundred dollars to be in
fact and i saved twenty dollars using
honey but honey hasn't just saved conor
a lot of money that's me honey has found
it's over 70 million members over two
billion dollars in savings gentlemen if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out on free
savings so what are you waiting for get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey dot com
slash trash taste
oh my god back to the episode okay so i
need to know what have you watched jojo
it's my passion my love in life
i'm afraid to say no
cancel the episode oh my god cancel it
move on and move on in the episode
you dare
sit behind and call yourself a
delinquent
and jojo practically invented
delinquents i'm pretty sure
before jojo there was no there was no
delinquents before josuke bro
pay your respect
okay the god of delinquents
he's actually a very nice guy helps the
community out so he's holly at lincoln
no i'm kidding i think you would love it
though i think you'd like it a lot yeah
oh um wait wait wait um can i ask you
this is um
kishibe rohan a part of jojo yes indeed
he's in part four how do you know about
kishiba rohan oh
i've seen that before
i've read i've read the kishibe rohan
comics i know that
oh the the immovable kishimoto yeah but
i didn't know it was jokes you watched
the spin-off
it's just phenomenal it's a speech it's
like watching the like jar jar binks
like web comic
instead of watching star wars if i
watching the star wars christmas special
before star wars
you know i've i've heard of people
skipping parts
that's a
which is meant to be the biggest sin to
any jojo fans what level do we put just
starting with the side story
were you not confused
no it just because that spin-off is
confusing even for fans because the
episodes aren't in the correct order
characters just turn up as well yeah
like we know from prior did you like it
i i really liked it
you'll love jojo then you should go and
watch like proper like
but not the spin-off jojo i can't
believe i can't i can't look you in the
eye right now
am i gonna get killed after this no i'm
just disappointed okay so i'm just
disappointed
something about your energy though says
that i think you'll really yeah
if you if you love the rohingya one you
will love jojo yeah yeah yeah because
rocky is just georgia wait jojo has like
uh boos right ichiba
they said boobs
yeah yeah so it's split up into parts
and then each of the different parts
have different protagonists they're
different main characters but kishiba
rohan's not a protagonist oh it's nice
no he's the main character he's he is
amazing like an important sidekick very
important very important yeah he's a
side character that everyone loves yeah
he's a side character but he's not in
any of the ichibou neighbors he's in
he's in yombu yeah
that you started there how did you how
did you even start there how did that
happen netflix
no um i read the jump comics
oh
okay okay okay okay that means i thought
it makes a little more sense
to happen
no
oh my god i wish i could have watched
you reading it just to see like how
confused
what the [ __ ] is going on but i enjoyed
it it's fun i mean i really like the
rocky bear it's a great side story the
anime is amazing as well yeah yeah i
gotta say i my favorite one did you read
all of the raw and get your bait ovas or
just some of them side story side
stories
i don't know i i don't know the uh i
don't know there's one okay okay tell me
if this sounds familiar tell me this
sounds good
he goes to a gym
and there's a guy who he's running with
at the gym
have you read this one
no i i love this one so god damn much i
love that one yeah it's just like
they don't know how to explain it he
just goes to the gym and starts racing
against a guy who then wants to then
beat him wait i know right right right
right it's so good this is like one of
the this is this does not get memed
enough this bit it's like peak jojo yeah
have you seen it yeah it's so good and
then the guy's obsessed with protein and
then like oh my god it's just so
i love it please watch the rohan ovas if
you like jojo you will love it just
watch jojo and jenna it's amazing it's
amazing yeah it's bad i'll start okay
but i'll i'll tell you the order you
have to watch it in so you start with
one
and then you go two and then two and
then you go three and three yeah and
then you go four then
has already broken that so yeah
rohan keisha based side story then part
nine probably
first first chapter of part nine
all right so you haven't watched shows
here what are you currently into then
what are you doing there now i'm into
gundam right now
didn't expect that gundam like gunpla
and stuff yeah gunpla i started making
gunpla stuff i'm doing a gunplum making
stream
and it's really fun it's a rich man's
house uh what's your favorite gundam my
favorite gundam um i um i'm i'm a fan of
a
turn a
oh tiny gundam okay yes yes i like it i
understand
i like the metal orphans one
yes
i don't know anything about gundam i'm
so sorry i like the metal hemoglobin
orphan
i don't know anything about gundam i'm
just again pretending
i think we're all pretending because the
only gundams i've seen unfortunately are
like the mainstream gundams like uh like
wing and like wings
have you been a fan of gundam for a long
time or is it just recently you got into
it recently oh okay how did you get into
it
um
first of all it was gunpla i love making
stuff i
um cosplay yeah yeah yeah
i love sewing i love making little stuff
and it became like um making
gangnam
i got into it i don't know because i had
time i'm a streamer
to be fair it is like perfect stream of
content it's like a just chatting stream
with something to distract you yeah yeah
yeah
yeah because like i really wanted to get
into it as well but i'd know so little
about the gunpla world that i didn't
even know you didn't even know about the
graves i didn't even know about the
greatness
yeah there's um there's hg yeah uh high
grade i think it stands for high grade
these are all on the boxes
it's on it i didn't know this why has no
one told me this
hg for beginners yeah so i'm starting
from eight four k four i just recently
made um rg which is um
is it real real
real grade
[ __ ]
and then pg is predator grade obviously
you're great
hell yeah i'm getting it
the only reason i know about gunpla is
mostly through my editor allen who's
also a mecha fan he's obsessed with that
big gundam fan as well i've i've built a
few gunpla in my life
huh
yeah actually do you know do you want to
know how i started off uh discovering
gunpla
so my cousin like because here's the
thing gunpla and like gundam and mecca
in general was like super super massive
in southeast asia and i know a lot of
people who actually like they don't even
know gundam but they build gunpla right
because they're just a massive fan of
gunpla as opposed to me right now yeah
yeah exactly right yeah
the gunplaws are more appealing on the
show so i remember i every time i'd go
to my cousin's house
and if you've been watching trash chase
this was the cousin that uh showed me uh
showed me scary movies when i was a
pride right so where you know he's
basically my older brother but i
remember every time i'd go to his house
he had this room and he had this cabinet
right that was just basically just
gunpla it was all gunpla
and that's how
i knew what gunpla was right
um so i didn't know you had to build it
so
be me i'm like five six-year-olds i see
a cabinet full of giant robots what do i
think they're toys
that's not on six your card that's not
honestly okay so the first time
the first time i i think the first time
i remember going to that room
um he like he like goes to the toilet or
something where his mom calls him i
don't remember but he leaves me alone in
that room for like a good you know 10 15
20 minutes so what do i do
um i want to start playing with the toys
so so i didn't know i thought in
olympics yeah so so this is this is like
i'm describing the pain olympics now so
i see them all on the shelf and i
grabbed two i grabbed two off the shelf
and they start fighting right and then
of course they're giant robots in my
hand what are they to do they're going
to start [ __ ] fighting so i start
going
because i think they're [ __ ]
transformers or something right you know
you know
exactly like the bbc but like yeah of
course so so i started playing around
with them things start flying off i
think like a [ __ ] laser sword breaks
i don't [ __ ] know i'm like six year
old and like
when my cousin
comes in he was literally he literally
had a bottle of water in hand he drops
it it was like you know you know that
you know that scene in a movie where
like the person sees something they drop
the coffee he actually just [ __ ] did
that and i didn't know he was in the
room until i heard the water bottle drop
falls in slow motion
this is the only time i think he's ever
shouted at me in my life
i don't blame him
yeah i mean i i think that's when he's
like started showing me scary movies
because like
he's got to get me back somehow just
like that scene in community when he
walks in with the pizzas and the whole
place is on fire
i guess i guess gumballs are kind of
like sophisticated legos in some ways
right kind of yeah it's like really
difficult because yeah
you know you think about it the way i
think about it is that you're the mini
the poo ween
you know the mini the poo meme with the
ones
[ __ ] my brain winnie the pooh meme yeah
the one with like he's in a suit yeah
legos yeah yeah gunpla
i know i'm no gunfire fans to be pissed
off
at legos but come on they're [ __ ]
legos how dare you compare i i had these
things with called like did you have did
you guys ever have these things called
like meccano
did you i had bionicle shout out to
bionicle yeah that's bionicle so there
was like it was like lego and then you
move on to bionicle which is like kind
of difficult
like and then mcconnell introduces like
screws oh i think i remember this yeah
yeah and like metal parts and then you
can build like tanks and [ __ ] out of it
screw the parts together yeah yeah yeah
so it's like instead of lego that just
kind of like fit together you you get
like small screws and likes and like
little hooks and stuff like that and you
like actually screw it in
and then on top of that is gambler
that's in my head that's like the
difficulty spike i feel so now that i've
like spent my childhood playing meccano
i'm like i'm ready for the next step do
you ever get sean point stressed out
building it when you're trying to like
fit a piece together that feels like it
shouldn't be going together but the
guide is like no no you put that piece
together and you feel like you're gonna
break something i always get so nervous
around that when i'm building gunpla
it's it's like zen to me
i feel like you need to be there yeah
yeah yeah i get too stressed out yeah
it's very therapeutic
therapy it's like doing a jigsaw puzzle
i feel it's like you gotta be in zen
mode otherwise you're just gonna rage we
did a we did a race of a gambler
it was still a model kit but uh yeah
that wasn't that wasn't fun that wasn't
yeah
um
when you add when you add a relaxing uh
relaxing activity and put a time limit
on it it just suddenly it doesn't become
relaxing anymore what can i say
that's why you rarely see like jigsaw
puzzle speed runs just because it would
be so that sounds fun we should have
that's so stress inducing i mean i'd
love to do it but that sounds like an
amazing idea yeah big soul puzzle speed
i bet there's like there's there's
strats we haven't developed yet because
we're just too afraid everyone's just
like oh yeah just find the corners there
must be a way to like optimize it more
yeah you know speedrunners come on get
on it get on this but yeah come on what
are the strats oh my god jigsaw puzzle
i love jigsaw puzzles oh my god
have you ever met anyone who said i
[ __ ] hate jigsaw puzzles uh
no i'm not hate i've never met anyone
who loves them they're just clearly not
very polarizing i mean it's a
[ __ ] piece of cardboard you stick
together like
what's what's not to like i used to be
breaking down first i mean it's like
saying it's like does anyone have any
angry feelings towards like connect four
it's like no it's like it's connect four
no one feels strongly
about it or against it sure people who
uh [ __ ] at connect four yeah probably
how are you [ __ ] at connect four it's
not hard thank you actually
i'll tell this other people who keep
losing a connect four what about okay
what about norton crosses what do you
call it in australia would you call it
tic-tac-toe
they're called naughts and crosses in
the uk
i mean it's like well i'm sure
tic-tac-toe notes and crosses is like
stress-inducing the people who are
shocked
no it's like when you play that one dude
who clearly just knows the winning strat
and i'll just go for the middle and
we'll just beat you every time
you know then it's like then then i can
start to see people being like [ __ ] this
even though it's fundamentally just a
bunch of lines on a piece of paper
rightly right
still be stressing juicy
why are we talking about this i can't
remember i don't know where are we going
yeah going back yeah go back to gunpla
so what is your favorite model kit that
you've built so far then um i've built
um
a [ __ ]
yeah
it's the one that's kind of like short
and dumpy right yeah yeah yeah
why did you just say yeah yes it's shawn
dumpy look at him yeah and that was my
first rg so oh
okay it was really hard i i hurt my
fingers
the parts like have to
move around the parts
right you know you know what i mean it's
like without breaking it right yeah
without breaking it it was so hard i was
like so stressful good i haven't had
enough time building ikea furniture you
know
like
it's like that but if the couch is this
big where's the perfect grade ikea
furniture that's what i want to know
it's already hard enough yeah
there's no such thing as a high grade
ikea furniture it starts on like master
grade
i get ptsd whenever i thread thread the
uh the screw too much
and then it's like halfway in
the screw you're like oh no oh no i've
got like three turns left before this is
gone and then it starts making that like
horrible squeaking sound
i definitely like building gunpla up to
a point and then like you finish it and
then you're like what's this thing that
i haven't used and it's the [ __ ]
stickers and that's that that's when it
goes from uh that's when it goes from a
uh like a relaxing
activity to just the worst thing i could
ever hope for i wish i liked it
yeah right i wish i was into it because
it would just be something you can do
like on a rainy day right you know yeah
but like i i know there's like my kids
could play with them
[Music]
you can watch their soul leave their
bodies
i think what happens
but i know there's like hardcore gambler
uh
modelers in japan that you know go to
the effort of like you know when you
like snip off the little bits of plastic
yeah and then there's like those little
bits yeah
they're like no no they don't even cut
it they sand it wait yeah yeah i stand
sandy oh you do the sanding
how do you deal with people backseating
you while you're building it do you have
people like telling you what to do oh
there are people every time i punch them
in the face
shut up no one told me what to do i'm a
delinquent i do what i want to do
oh my god i will send it i will do what
i want but i'm going to stand up
[Music]
as if like as if like game back seating
was already like the worst thing ever
could you imagine someone like um you
you haven't sanded this part enough i
didn't realize what would be the worst
thing to have a backseating experience
with until it happened and it's chess
chess is by far the worst game to play
on stream because of backseating
everyone is like e4 e4 e3 everyone just
says [ __ ] i can't believe you made that
move sometimes i wish people didn't know
how to play chess maybe they wouldn't
backseat so much like
playing chess because i remember when i
played chess in like the chess
tournament i had to like learn to not
look at the chat because
like you know you know that sinking
feeling where you've just moved the
piece and you've realized you've just
like hung a queen or something like that
yeah that's like playing with chat is
just that feeling but just constantly
yeah right
are you a chess player no i i know
nothing about chess
did you know any like strategy board
games like mahjong or uh i play my
channel i love my giants you play
mahjong yeah you play
i'm really good at it really i got i got
gaunt into it recently
it got to the point where i bought a
mahjong table for my house wow yeah i'll
eventually play it yeah we need to get
connor oh yeah stream
stream let's go
stream hell yeah hell yeah you know if
we played enough eventually the viewers
are going to learn the rules of the game
yeah because yeah i mean i saw you
streaming mahjong and uh like how how
much were the viewers able to follow
along like like ten percent of them
ten percent of them like yeah i saw my i
saw my grandma playing this once
before but yeah i think it's like it's
one of those games where like the more
you watch someone play it the more you
start to just understand the game like
because like i'm not necessarily like
good at the game yeah but i've gotten to
the point now where i watch like
professionals playing it on youtube and
just watching them play it is like oh
[ __ ] now i like understand more now
about like the strategies of the game do
you like trash talk in the middle of the
match no they're super quiet
i wish it was like poker where they're
just like talking [ __ ] to each other the
whole time
that's pretty cringe bro
do you only play like online or have you
ever played with real tiles as well with
i've never played with the real ones i
only only the online my john where i
learned it from um oh learn it from real
go to the yakuza series oh yeah you
learned it from yakuza
i think everyone learns it from that
though they teach you in it how to play
it yeah so in every everyday
game there's like a place where you can
go and play mahjong in the game it's
like a tutorial it's a mini game it's
like a mini game because this is the
thing where is the best place to learn
how to play major i learned it through
the uh you know on the nintendo switch
there's the 50 classic board games
that's how you learn to play marketing
yeah and they have mahjong on there and
i was like i'm going to give it a go and
then i just got into it from there yeah
it's like a tutorial yeah yeah yeah if
anything like online games are the way
to go because i didn't realize this
until joey invited me over to play like
physical mahjong how much online games
hold your hand to like tell you what's
going on and uh what you can put down
and what like the strats are right so i
remember i was like a complete beginner
at mahjong barely knew the rules play
once with like joey and suddenly like
you know it was like training with the
master and then going back to the novice
level when i played online again i was
like wait they highlight all the tars
for you
and they tell you all the hands what is
this what is this baby mode that i'm
playing wrong yeah because like the one
time i played it like irl was gone we
had like one of our friends who's like
way better at it um and like i think i
learned like 20 new rules just from that
like short session i was like oh you can
do that
if you drop a child you're three seconds
to eat it yeah yeah i'm not gonna
pretend i understand all the rules
because like there are some hands where
you know it's so deep yeah yeah maki
would do something and he'd suddenly get
like 10 times the amount of points i was
getting and i'm just like you know i'm
just i'm just going to let this happen i
don't i don't know what's going on uh
but i'm having fun it's it's one
experience we're having fun yeah this is
rule number one have fun
oh my god
do you want to instantly sound like a
boomer that's all you have to say
have you ever done any mahjong streams
yourself or is it just a private thing i
did it yesterday oh really okay yeah
with my viewers i i play with my viewers
really fun always having fun do they not
like did they not stream snipe you
though if you're playing with viewers
they
um because i did a once on stream and
like two guys yeah i got stream sniped
i've had that before yeah yeah but like
there's nothing more frustrating than
getting streams tonight with mahjong
it's like getting stream tonight with
poker well they can look at your stuff
yeah they can look at my hand just on
stream it's the worst i just trust them
and
look at my
you put a lot of trust in your youtube
jealous
dreams
your viewers are nice would you say that
uh the japanese audience is very polite
in that sense then they won't stream
stamp you're trying to [ __ ] around with
you yeah that's good they are my view my
chat loves to [ __ ] ruin my day
that's what they get off one day i'm
kidding i love your chat but [ __ ] you
chad
my god
oh my god yeah that's that's basically
like a lot of western people just like
especially with our audience they love
to troll us yeah that's that's where the
content is for us i guess right exactly
exactly viewer interaction so like what
are your favorite types of streams that
you do
my favorite types of streams
types
types like just chatting or games or
or gunpla gun plus
i'm into gunpla right now so i really
enjoy gunpla
um
but but if you could do only one type of
stream
for the rest of your career what
then i play games games yeah games like
arc and survival stuff you like arc
right yeah i love arc i couldn't get
into that game i wish i could have tried
it what's what is that game
it's a survival crafting dinosaurs
isn't it kind of like a real minecraft
i think so
it's like squid game
i i only know arc right because it was
like my friends who played the like
four xd strategy games those types of
games wasn't like
basically strategy on like on like meth
it's like strategy games like times a
thousand yeah like they're very hard
what they called like it makes civ look
like it's for babies like these kind
i've got there's a bunch that i have
downloaded because i try to play them
but they're learning them are way too
different yeah yeah yeah those types of
friends i have that love those games
love ark and i was like that's a good
sign for me to not go near arc because
their game taste is like horrible it's
like minecraft but there's like there's
like dinosaurs in here yeah there's
dinosaurs in it
like a caveman right you have one minute
to sell us on ark oh oh no
go time starts now don't you want to
punch those streets and make your own
house
arc is for you
so what else what else can we do casey
i'll tell us yeah what else can you do
in hawk you can poop with your clothes
on
you guys should have an obsession with
this
have you ever wanted to play minecraft
but poop at the same time can you build
a play otherwise connor's not going to
be interested
um i think so there's a toilet and you
can poop in it
so so far uh
so far the benefits to arc uh you can
poop
i mean trash chase viewers should love
that right yeah trash taste viewers are
sold
toilet so you gotta ah what else you
into
i'm into arc and you know conan exiles
you ever heard of it
i've heard of that exactly what is that
it's like arc
[ __ ] well there's no dinosaurs
there's monsters so it's like so it's
like minecraft okay okay what else what
else do you like
is that not correct
that's what it sounded like it's like
minecraft but hd you're not into uh
you're not into apex legends the one
that every game every gamer in japan is
playing right now
do you like fps
i do like it but i'm so bad at it i'm
i'm not good at it
sounds like you like the crafting kind
of games sandbox
that makes sense i'm a crafting person
have you ever played subnautica
yeah i love that game oh that's crafting
barney
oh my god finally finds
i've been meaning to play in vr yeah
minecraft but you can't poop in it
unfortunately so uh
so you know that's that's all that's uh
some that's a tick off but it's
basically like a
survival crafting game where
if you wanna experience like
talasophobia without experiencing
right it actually like it
brings out i don't know what that was
it's called phobia it's like a
fear of like open water yeah did you
learn that from that game no i literally
it okay so i've common word
how often do you say that as often as i
say archipelago
[ __ ] no [ __ ] off don't did you know
that word
yeah exactly
no get out of here
you don't know this word
i actually i learned it because because
i played subnautica and then you know
youtube algorithm works in mysterious
ways and suddenly i started getting
recommended videos about
telassophobiaphobia simulator and it's
just like ah that's the thing that i
feel when i play subnautica so it's
basically just you know a fear of open
water so it's like if you see an image
and it's just
you submerge in the ocean and you can't
see an island or anything like that or
you just see like deep water that you
can't see the bottom that's kind of that
kind of like subnautica gives you such a
good feeling or such a great feeling of
that god i can't imagine that in vr
that'd be [ __ ] terrible yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's actually i don't think
it's actually meant to be a horror game
but my god there are some moments that
that [ __ ] scared i thought it was a
horror game it looks like a horror
everyone's so scared playing were you
scared
it's it's really scary when you have to
go deep down to find something that you
know it's there's there's a lot of
things hidden in the deep water yeah
cause i've seen so many clips in
subnautica where just like you just be
swimming and they're just like a shark
three frames right yeah that's like the
most famous part of it yeah yeah yeah
so so like you start off in subnautica
in like the shallow area right where you
know the kiddie pool the kiddie pool you
can see the sunlight there's coral
around you're like yeah this is cool i
love i love scuba diving this is awesome
and then you kind of realize soon after
that some of the things that you need to
craft aren't in this area that you're in
so you look over to the area next to it
and it's just darkness and then you soon
realize that you're gonna have to build
up the courage to go in that new area so
it's finding nemo simulator kind of yeah
kind of kind of and what it does such a
great job at is just it's the fear of
the unknown right because you don't know
exactly what's in the water but
sometimes you you hear a sound you look
around you're like what the [ __ ] going
on you know you're checking looking
yeah because i like normally i [ __ ]
hate horror games right because i hate
jump scares i hate jump scares the most
and uh yeah subnautica i mean it doesn't
intentionally give you jump scares
obviously natural jumps it's it's a
natural jump scare but uh like it does
give you this feeling of just uneasiness
like you're swimming in the ocean and
you feel someone grabbing your feet
that kind of feeling you know
um so it's and it's it's just a very fun
crafting survival game as well
is minecraft like that i would like to
know because then i would then i would
play minecraft i mean i think kinda
there's some places you can run into
stuff like that i mean you know i think
like whenever you first meet like a
creeper and enderman that's pretty much
a jump scare right yeah you died really
easy early on so it's pretty scary yeah
what's the creep you love
creeper
you will love ark because ark you can go
what are you laughing at
what are you laughing at
you can go go down water you can go deep
there's caves
it's really it's arc it's uh monica is
arc without the poop
dinosaurs
specifically
to be fair name another crafting game
where you can poop in
other than ark
is there any
is there any i think it's my it might
only be really famous for pooping it
really is
just google arkansas why are you are you
sure arc is famous for pooping or are
you trying to make it famous are you
trying to make your face google it right
now ark poop why is
why is pooping in the game what does
that help with
because you can use it for like to like
manure and stuff
like crafting materials
i've just seen compilations of v tubers
reacting to dinosaurs pooping an arc and
they just like lose their mind what
compilation yeah
[Music]
when they learn you can poop in the game
and these little laughs they're awesome
okay i will link you the video
yeah
you can use the poop as like manure to
like grow crops in the game i'm pretty
sure and there's a dinosaur that that
only
uh exists for pooping
my entire existence is poop yeah
you know you know that twitter account
which is just you can pet the dog which
is like different games and tell you if
you compare the dog can you poop in the
game can you is that a poop in this game
no
twitter it's always going to be no can
you poop in this game
it's like it's just like fan account
no you cannot poop in legend of zelda
so other dinosaurs actually scary an arc
or
does that even interest you to begin
with but you can tame them you can tame
donna you can tame them and you can you
can go to capes with them they can fight
for you
they can live with you that sounds cool
see that sounds pretty damn epic can you
do that in subnautica
no you can you can have like a little
fish tank where you like raise your own
fish but that's pretty much it all right
probably like train fish can you you can
tame like a dolphin
in conan exiles you can tame human
[Music]
isn't there a word for
i was like i'm pretty sure you can do
that in real life as well i don't think
you should but you know that's how they
solve did we abolish that like
that's how they sell slavery in the
modern day it's taming like
no
it's taming yeah
i can't believe a reality ripped off
like that
with a stick
hit their heads really hard like five or
six times um knock them out and then
chain it to some
i don't know that
something
would make it like
labor it's so random that you put your
current exiles that that game was big
like a few years back does anyone still
play conan exiles i do
is it still big why'd you call her out
like that man i'm sorry i just i don't
know anyone else who plays quite an
exile still that is the only one i
remember there was like drama between
youtubers when one of them like
destroyed the other's base or something
and it genuinely caused like drama they
actually had a falling out because you
could destroy each other's base in the
game that also happened in like rust as
well i think so yeah yeah there was like
drama around that as well you do that on
arc as well yeah yeah you
is there like an etiquette to the game
or does that normally i think there is
etiquette in games like that
and if someone like [ __ ] everything up
you're like he's not allowed on servers
again yeah just banned him from the
server
yeah i imagine i imagine this is like
the perfect
uh concoction for that [ __ ] south
park warcraft episode where there's just
one guy killing everyone right classic
pretty much you've been uh youtubing
independently since october
october yes how has it been being
independent
um
well it's really
fun yeah i'm having fun of course but um
it's really busy but yeah yeah i made my
first merch
october it was my debut merch
it was really hard i
i hired a manager
first time in my life i didn't know i'm
gonna do that
my daddy is so so surprised i told him
that i hired a manager what the [ __ ]
anime girls need a manager
every anime girl needs a manager yes
father this is 2021. 2021.
i guess 2020. is the merch still on sale
or
uh it's not on sale um
right now
but it's sold well
so what is the added that's
yeah i'll be down for buying a case on
gunplur you said yeah seriously that's
that's the next statement that's the
next stage because plenty of youtubers
have figures now no one has gunpla you
know
you know owning a waifu isn't enough you
need to build you got to build
yeah because i mean
you know when you started individual i
think you uh i think you you know blew
up pretty quickly um did you expect the
reaction that you got from doing
individual tubing oh no no no no
i
honestly i
i didn't expect anything
right what happened i was like
i mean yeah because especially now like
the individual is so massive right it's
so insanely competitive like
it's like getting like new v tours
coming up like 10 v2 words in a day
yeah it's crazy yeah it's crazy to see
you new streams debut streams
every day yeah i feel every time i go
into twitter like another one of my
friends is becoming a vegan yeah
or i see a lot of twitter accounts that
have pre-debut or something oh yeah
that's the one i see now where they're
going to debut but they haven't debuted
yet but they're like
on twitter yeah they show like like a
two second clip yeah yeah they're
they're they're saying like they're
preparing yeah i see a lot of those it's
like three days till debut or something
yeah yeah a lot of those that's just
like the magic word debut like i said
you know right like we have like [ __ ]
what outfit debuts now we go yeah what
else can we like do what else can
youtubers do like
like updated model debuts yeah
you did that right you got a new model
made right from the original one this is
my model 3.0 ooh i saw a model that was
quite interesting uh where you just had
half of your body
what was going on with that how where
did that idea come from have you seen
this what is it do you want to explain
this model i'll let you explain it i
don't want to explain explain it to the
boys um
uh you've seen the one with my my with
my real body
this is so genius from you i have to say
this was big brain this was so smart i
used my camera and well i i i didn't put
i didn't want to put my makeup on so um
i cut my head off and then wore the same
costume as my model because i had them i
had the costume i made the costume
myself and then made the model oh okay
yeah so i had the same one so why not
just put my head off
so it's so small you had like her head
was like here and then you could just
see her chest and i was like okay so
what are you doing
it was so juicy i remember seeing that i
thought that was photoshopped yeah i
thought that was like meme fan accounts
just uh making that i did a stream
i can do it now
that was that was genius i have to say i
was i was very impressed by that i
thought that how has nobody thought of
that that's so big bro but some fans
hated it wait why are they hated
i don't know my japanese fan like um i
said before um doesn't like uh to see
the real
the real real
[Laughter]
for lack of a better way of phrasing
this is they're scared of real boobs
no it's not like that they just
they want to keep the fantasy i think i
see it so yes
so yes
it's like that uh it's like that uh real
boobs all out that clip from the
simpsons where uh smithers is in the
club and the women are like
sorry i'll show you later this week
because
yeah it was so strange though that they
would get angry like angry or just they
didn't like you some people got really
angry
because i guess it like breaks the
illusion right why would they get angry
about it though maybe just dislike of it
i can understand but like getting upset
over it feels like so stupid
yeah
yeah
i'm glad you agree i'm glad you agree
i'm like what the [ __ ] it's a weird
thing to get angry about to be honest
what you should do is you should just
like slowly lead them in so maybe how
like start off with ten percent 3d other
than like 20 3d and then like maybe they
didn't like it because i went all the
way yeah yeah oh yeah so like every
stream you do just like take off like a
pixel do 50 50. right down the middle
down the middle down the middle
and you'll be like harvey two-faced
yeah like a like a movie poster
i should try that next
i want to make someone mad with that
yeah let's do that
i guess i guess it's like the same logic
of like you know uh
like
people who love say for example like an
anime character right but they separate
the anime character from the voice
actress right yeah they want to keep it
separate yeah um because they want to
because they want to think to themselves
oh this 2d character is
an actual like real character not not
played by anyone but it's like a real
thing right and like it's that
yeah because you know these lines are
recorded and they are then given two set
characters right but when you're
streaming i feel like it's different
it's always a person yeah i still feel
that there's a lot of japanese viewers
who haven't
differentiated between the two though i
just don't understand how you could
because the whole appeal of the
you know if they wanted to be obsessed
with just 2d models they would just go
and watch anime but it's a 2d model you
can interact with through the chat right
that's that's where the selling point is
for a lot of people so when you do do io
streams is it that your western audience
that gives you a more positive reception
yeah yeah definitely definitely yes okay
because i i think we have i think the
phrase here in like the western
community is a touch grass
that's referring to what god i don't
know
that's what we're telling you referring
to japanese viewers no no that's what we
tell each other when people are too far
off the deep end yeah they can't tell
reality from fiction right yeah before
you decided to become
be tuba cason
was there a point where you were like 50
50 or you weren't sure whether to go
like irl or was it just you're like no
i'm gonna go youtuber right away there's
no doubt in your mind
[Music]
let me say i'm still struggling
going back and forth with that real life
and be tubing what should i do um
because some people really like my real
live streaming and some people hate it
and some people really love my youtubers
yeah their streaming and
art well there's there's um i don't know
it's tough
[Music]
i don't know what to say i
there are a bunch of people watching
right now so um
like um i think you'd be honest about it
yeah yeah you can be honest
to be honest yeah to be honest it's
really easy for me to use this model
to do the
real life because my
my face is always messed up and my room
is really messy i do not want to film in
there so i would disagree but all right
yeah
i don't think your face is quote un
messed up
point me to someone who is not messed up
and yeah
i wanna everyone looks messed up in the
morning you know i would say in general
just do which one you think you you can
keep doing for the longest time yeah you
know i i used to do only
uh [ __ ] oh my god used to only do
like sebastian from black butler you
know
yeah oh yeah my channel the way i
started my youtube channel was i used to
just do his voice
in like english sound really posh
english and all my videos are me just
like prank calling places
uh as sebastian i remember back in those
good old days
like call people like this yes i suppose
i'm
really british oh dude the og fans are
creamy right now
but that's what he sounded like in
english right so um yeah i did that for
a very long time but then i was getting
to the point where i was like you know
what i don't i don't think i want to be
a character anymore i think i just want
to be me i think i think i want to be me
and that was what happened for me so i
don't know you know what i don't think i
will
but you know it was i got a lot of
pushback when i when i started uh doing
uh well not push back more so that just
no one turned up
nobody wanted to watch that's that's so
normal though like like when you when
you drastically change your [ __ ] that
much right it's like yeah of course
which means you're not a butler in real
life what is this what is this
unfortunately not but i wish who makes
the coffee
the intern
[Music]
the real bottle the real butler
um but yeah you know it's i'd say if you
have any if you you know if you if there
is a part of you that's like yeah dude i
would like to do more i'll stop i'll
just go for it like
there will there's always pushback in
the start but that you know you will
gain the audience of a new
people who appreciate you can't please
everyone
never ever ever let the viewers what
they want decide what you want to do
it's your life not theirs right well
that's so true i love you viewers there
by the way uh
i subscribed let us know down below what
you want to see from us uh
yeah sorry we don't talk about anime but
clearly clearly clearly uh we've made
that choice not to exactly
if you're doing content that is to
appease someone
you're not making the best content you
can make you're making content that you
think is the best content it's really
going to like you're only going to be
able to do it for so long until you get
to that point where you just want to you
know throw everything away and be like
[ __ ] it i don't want to do this there
are there are some times in the venn
diagram where they overlap and what the
viewers want and what you want right
right right that's just absolutely weird
absolutely everyone's happy yeah happy
little accident yeah unfortunately
doesn't happen yeah yeah except the only
problem is that vendor is like this
it's tiny
so like before v tubing you said you
were into cosplaying so how did you get
into that
oh it's a long story
love um
um do you know
a visual k bands yeah of course
and i was a fan of visual cave bands and
that's where i started cosplaying my
first cosplay was a visual k band
cosplay what was the band what what
bands were you into um the band um i
don't think you guys know it but it's
called gazette oh yeah gazette yeah you
guys know it i don't know the gazette
you don't know i'm not going to pretend
i do i'm sorry
i used to cosplay as a member of that
and other visual key visual key bands
that's where i started
like nightmare and like oh yeah
gilgamesh and all those guys oh you know
gilgamesh i love gilgamesh oh
yeah yeah
yeah
that makes a lot of sense actually
because yeah that is started from there
it wasn't from anime everyone thinks
it's from anime but it wasn't
i was banned from anime
i was banned from it was visual visual
okay aloud though
um
i
don't think so but my
my parents didn't know anything about it
so they weren't able to ban it from me
because a lot of a lot of visual cave
bands are pretty like raunchy yeah i
know i know yeah like you listen to like
duron gray it's like oh my god i don't
want my kids listening to that jesus
christ
so did you start off making your own
cosplays or did you
buy your cosplays at first and then you
kind of learnt it along the way i was
making it because my mommy my mommy is
really good at sewing she teach me how
to show
when i was little and i was kind of
into sewing so i started i was really
interested in the costumes right the
visual k bands costumes are really
really awkward
yeah you guys know it it's really yeah
it's insane cool it's insane so i really
i was like i saw it as art
and i really wanted to make it make one
so i started it and then i end up being
an anime girl
no i i did you do like the visual okay
makeup as well yeah yeah yeah yeah i
used to i used to have no eyebrows
wait why
so you draw it off
oh yeah they don't have it oh
most visual key visual okay people don't
have eyebrows
i did a video with the visual cave and i
don't remember
if they had
eyebrows i'm trying to remember if they
had eyebrows
i mean i mean it's not like it's not
like a requirement
you made it sound like it was a thing
where it's a greeting it's like oh you
want to be a visual caveman give it to
my brother get rid of the eyebrows
funny image of like visual k bands with
like the eyebrows photoshopped out have
you seen someone without eyebrows it
looks really weird that looks super yeah
scary i would know because i i had to
like shave my eyebrows off uh because
when i went became a monk yeah and that
looked like 10 times weirder than me
having a bold head right the bonehead
meant nothing because all i could see
was just like my eyebrow less [ __ ]
face yeah it was it's super [ __ ]
weird i can't describe wait did you have
the shaved head with no eyebrows yeah
no hair
double whammy she's just like [ __ ] mr
potato head or something no even here
even he has [ __ ] eyebrows doesn't he
he does he's got like a lovely bushy
eyebrows when he like loses his parts
and just like it's just like his eyes
and her mouth that's what it looked like
it looks so weird so i've noticed in
some of your streams you've done a lot
of meme reviews
oh yeah
yeah so
what that's good what nothing i'm
smiling
connor's smiling what is that
yeah so i wanted to ask like how what's
your opinion between like japanese memes
versus western memes right because i've
only like i only get like a glimpse of
japanese memes every now and again so i
don't really know what kind of memes are
even hot or popular what like the sense
of humor is what is what is your opinion
on that well i only review like um
western memes so i i don't know much
about japanese memes but i've seen some
and i only reviewed uh those
western memes i
because i
understand the jokes right right
are you trying to say you don't
understand what to say are you trying to
say western memes are better yeah that's
kind of what i wanted to be honest
to be honest i prefer the western memes
over the japanese memes yeah japanese
memes it's
so weird it's so weird and complicated
for me sometimes i really don't
understand why they're doing it like
like i i feel the baseline japanese meme
is like the same level as a
multi-layered western meme where it's
where it's like you have to it's like
it's like reference over reference over
reference to like fully understand they
have anything like
uh oh stinky in in japanese i don't
think so you know uh-oh stinky i don't
know that
[Music]
stinky it's a really dumb meme
next time you do a meme review yeah you
okay this is one of those clips right
bear in mind this is like one way you
hear it first time you're like this is i
don't like this and then you hear it
five times you're like why is this so
funny
all right so me and joey going to talk
while uh connor
[Music]
what am i watching
[Laughter]
the pinnacle of western memes cases this
is like when you're trying to explain my
job to my mom
she just walks up to a dinosaur and goes
no japanese memes are not like that
i don't know why we have that kind of
humor in the way well there's some of
them but there are a bunch of other ones
as well yeah i do like our memes very
fond of them yeah sometimes i like
anti-memes as well and i like
sometimes
i don't know it's i can't even get my
own humor a lot of the time and
sometimes meme just don't make sense
what just i don't know
it is true because it's like the more
memes i've seen from both the japanese
and english side the more i don't know
what's funny anymore
i don't know what's humor anymore yeah
yeah
i can watch a a
stand-up comedy like yeah that's comedy
yeah and then i go to memes i'm like is
this comedy
i'm laughing like is this funny or is it
entertaining i don't know can you guys
describe a japanese meme that you found
for me
you know the one that everyone always
sung praises of japanese vine everyone
always said that was really good
i thought japanese japanese vine is
really good yeah and like and like a lot
of japanese tick tocks as well like
minus the ones where it's just like hot
girls dancing like the ones where it's
like actually you know divine energy
coming back onto tick-tock like some of
those are pretty funny but it's like i
don't know i feel a lot of like japanese
memes a lot more like very surreal where
it's like it's more like what the [ __ ]
is this more so than this is funny
kind of thing would you say that yeah
yeah yeah yeah well you look at it it's
like oh this is really weird but also
kind of entertaining but you don't you
don't necessarily like laugh at it yeah
you know
you guys uh do you know the uh the
japanese guy like standing in season oh
yeah thank you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know one yeah it's not funny
right
it's is that a fun that's not a funny
thing that's just great i love it but
that's a meme that's a japanese japanese
me i mean that's an inspiring meme
i'm like i'm like good good for you guys
i get behind that yeah but that's the
thing it's like i feel in japan memes
are used more as a creative outlet right
like as in like people take a meme that
is not necessarily funny but they
recreate it in different like artistic
ways to like kind of be like look what i
can do with this one thing that everyone
knows kind of thing whereas in the west
you get uh-oh stinky
sauce
and sauce where it's like it's funny
is it creative though
i'm not too sure like you know
there are a few words where that meme
has just ruined yeah for me like a monk
is one of them
like i got i can't hear them anymore
i love memes because they they almost
paint a picture of the current time like
yeah accurately you can really get a
sense of the the feel for the time with
with a meme yeah i think
memes are almost like a language yeah
they are they're right because
yeah you know what in [ __ ] 100 years
maybe memes will become a language in
itself because you know sometimes you
see a meme and you don't understand it
at all but sometimes you see a meme and
there are so many layers that are being
conveyed in this one meme that you just
get instantly right but then the problem
is with the explaining memes like that
people who don't get it is it you look
like a [ __ ] idiot when you have this
yeah they're like why are you telling me
that you find all of these things
individually funny and then when it's
combined you also find it even funnier
like what's wrong with you okay okay but
have you ever had a meme where you've
never heard of it before right someone
shows it to you you're just like what
the [ __ ] is this and he they explain why
it's funny and you're just like that's
not funny every time i just i just saw
it
every time every every meme i think it's
done
but then eventually you see it a second
time you're like oh that's that's kind
of amusing like you see the third time
so you give yourself a little chuckle um
come like the hundredth time you see
that meme and you're like [ __ ]
pissing yourself at one note in that
meme or something like that you know
that's that's like that's like memes to
me nowadays yeah yeah especially when
you're where it gets to the point where
you just have to listen to one
millisecond or like you start laughing
right now i've asked a lot of people
this what's your favorite meme my
favorite meme yeah did you get off the
top of your head what came to your head
first
it came to my
i don't know this one like something was
invented in 19 blah blah blah
but before that boom
do you know that
you guys
what about that meme do you like so much
oh oh oh
like this one oh i get it i get it yeah
like the depression was invented in 1856
people before depression yeah
it's just like a smiling dude
oh these ones okay i've seen these
better than oh stinky i think that's
that's right sure
i feel like oh stinky has the staying
power
sometimes you sometimes you see it
enough times you're like this ain't
funny anymore this ain't funny when you
wake up the next morning like okay this
is this is pretty damn funny
but that's that's that's the best memes
right the worst memes are the ones where
you see on twitter one day we see you on
tick tock and it lasts literally a day
i've seen memes just last a day
and
can you even call the memes at that
point no like it's just a funny image
like that's all it is
it's just some dude posted a funny image
and a lot of people liked it that's i
guess i guess that's what a meme isn't
yeah
i guess that is i guess that's what
congratulations joey i figured out what
a meme is that's a meme a meme that's a
meme
for the longest time i thought it was
maybe
when like when like troll comics were
first the thing
is it it's melee right
what melee like when you hit someone
like super smash brothers yeah yeah it's
melee when i was a kid i just like could
not ellie i like melly yeah
i called him millie when i was a kid
yeah m-e-l-e-e yeah
because when you say m-e-l-e-e like
melee milly that's another one of those
words where i remember to send me as a
child i just did not know which one it
was and i would kind of be like super
smash brother minnie
wait so is it melly or mealy i say melee
melee no wait what do i say i forgot
what i said now melee melee melee
okay yeah i'm i'm getting like a [ __ ]
um what's what's that moment called
where
your memory is different than what oh
the uh mandela effect yeah i'm getting a
mandela effect right now i think because
i swear when you booted up the game the
announcer pronounced it mainly
no no he didn't work he definitely did
it he goes like super smash brothers
melee
it wasn't an american accent i swear to
god it was but the guy doing it is an
american yeah i'm sure it's an american
yeah it's zander right now
xander who does it he's the one who does
the main voice of the he does joker
instead of five yeah
he he did that yeah it's the same guy
he's been voice lighting for that long
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] he's the announcer
for smash
i did not know that and i'm pretty sure
he says melee i think right does he does
he i think
mine's just blind i know nothing about
mario
when you play
mario
i don't know anything about pokemon i
know nothing about marriott
says along with you just like says a lot
about society says a lot about society
when you play a game english or japanese
are you picking which one you going for
um the first one that popped out
the first one it popped out yeah if it
popped so if it's japanese oh you
literally like yeah yeah yeah it's
either all it literally doesn't matter
it doesn't matter for me oh wow i just i
guess because you can play both right
yeah yeah oh my god i guess it's kind of
the same with me as well like if the
original is japanese if it's an
originally a japanese game i'll play it
in japanese unless i have to stream it
but if it's made from a western studio
then i'll play it it's like swiss people
with european versions they're like oh
which language i speak all of them
doesn't matter
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] off yeah um yeah so
now that we've discussed a lot a lot
about your vtuber activities i'm
wondering though what's the what's that
what's the grand plan for cason what's
what do you want to do what do you want
to achieve
where is cason going in 2020 yeah 2022.
you're allowed to tell us 2022.
[Music]
it's um
i don't know i just started off just
being
a normal delinquent i want to be a
worldwide delinquent
worldwide world's most famous delinquent
pit bull step aside there's another mr
worldwide
mr worldwide delinquent
uh i don't know i i just didn't set a
goal for myself you know just doing
taking it day by day yeah are you the
kind of person who like makes goals for
themselves in like
daily life or anything or are you just
kind of like uh i'll do whatever i want
kind of i'll do whatever i want kind of
person
that makes sense i feel like that's very
common amongst creative fields yeah yeah
uh well i mean there are people who are
compulsively planning every little
detail of that creation yeah yeah but i
think we're trying to do that once
what happened i did that once yeah it
just broke me down
my brain couldn't just fit
so when you make the like when you were
like making cosplays you're just kind of
winging it you're like i'm kind of
eyeballing it you wouldn't measure
anything you're just like i i never
measure oh my god okay and if it went
wrong
i feel that's like true talent though
right it's like people who are like i've
never cooked this thing in my life
two seconds look at the recipe it's like
yeah i can call it people who don't know
how to like play piano uh read the piano
they should learn it from my ear or
something oh yeah yeah people can like
hear from me that's crazy that's crazy
to me so i i can't i can't even play ddr
without like like in general i can't
play ddri though how do they people how
people are good at that game practice
it's insane yeah yeah like i it's like i
don't know if someone can explain it to
me but can you explain why some of like
the most famous composers to ever live
were like deaf deaf yeah how does that
work they just they just knew
they just
well i guess that's the biggest mystery
right it's not like like mozart was deaf
but he wrote his first symphony when he
was five years old
no both mozart
i'm pretty sure mozart was dead i'm
pretty sure beethoven's death yeah um
yeah beethoven i think wrote his first
symphony when he was like five years old
yeah and he's like he just he just knew
[ __ ] man what else what was i doing at
play i wonder
like you know now that's what i call
music one cause there's like two songs
around there i'm sure it was easier to
get get away with making something i
mean come on there was no we all know
beethoven invented music oh that was
like there was like
name a song before beethoven
cave music exactly
was neither blind or deaf yeah yeah oh
really
was blind no no
he wasn't and that's helen keller i'm
glad we fact-checked this
helen keller's face
wasn't there uh
i know there was like piano battles they
used to have back in the day that
sounded so cool yeah it's like a rap
battle of like where mozart like wiped
the floor with another famous uh
composer or something i think actually
something like that yeah she's such a
badass bro it's been a while because
it's got the hair bro you seen his hair
insane
i mean everyone had that kind of hair
back this was insane bro that man had a
massive mane he had to do oh man that
man was making music
[Laughter]
man discovers mozart
in 2022. he's making music
you know that new guy mozart
make some bangers dude
did you go to conventions anime
conventions i never went to the
conventions before would you be
interested yeah would you ever want to
go
oh yeah of course yeah okay here's the
thing would you go you wouldn't leave my
house would you go as your v tuber model
or would you would you do like the full
rtx render
and uh yeah attending like a cosplayer
would you attend a cosplay
i would love to attend in cosplay with
this socho cosplay oh oh yeah that'd be
pretty cool
imagine getting a picture with caisson
irl rtx turned on hd 4k
no mods necessary bro that'd be i'm sure
people would freak out yeah that'd be
awesome do you want to go to like cons
in america as well
oh what do you want to go to cons in
america as well or just japan
um i would love to go to america and do
that of course
before our show americans i imagine are
quite different from japanese yeah it is
yeah i'd say so
yeah from what i've heard i've not been
to a japanese convention at like right
now but what japanese conventions are
there aside from comic-con and comic-con
oh sorry comic-con
i haven't i haven't been to comic-con
but i've just heard not good things i've
from what i've seen it's just
a line that you
you join to buy things
yeah it's it's a it's a dojin convention
buy it and then get in another line buy
it get another line where credits do i
think america has the best cons i think
they do it good
uk sucks really yeah you uk you're so
bad uk doesn't have uk don't have cons
they have drinking parties with some
anime figures drinking parts
it's like in like but it's always in
like uh a venue where you'd have like a
school dance you know it's never like an
actual that it's small it's not like a
concert hall no you know it's literally
just a place to go drink people who like
anime because like
one thing i love about american cons is
that they have events going on happy
events like to me i remember going to my
first british con and seeing what their
events
like schedule was and it was basically
nothing you go there to drink right i
know even now huh yeah even now yeah
half of my panels were in a bar area
so
they got their priorities yeah they
would you'd have the panel and um like
if you were like put like i guess uh
perpendicular to it was it a bar so
while you're doing your panel people are
lining up to get beer and stuff
so it's like
like i don't even know what the biggest
anime convention in the uk is right now
you can't mcm yeah
what does it suck in uk
wow
round of applause for that ladies and
gentlemen
i would shake your hand case on but i
can't unfortunately but i'll do like a
virtual handshake oh god hold up where
did you hear this from who told you the
uk sucks
who told you this
who told you this huh um
but i don't hear anything that doesn't
suck
i just needed some information
to change my mind
we destroyed the most 5g towers per per
person i think that's the uk doesn't
suck change my mind
do you like pubs
uh yeah
as a delinquent you should then you'll
love it that's that's that's what we
have going for okay it's nothing but
pubs we have lots of pumps greg's you
wouldn't know what that is but
uh i think you'd like it
there's a certain chain called tesco's
oh yeah
fish and chips do you like fish and
chips fish i i don't eat fish and chips
in the uk
who doctor who is from the uk uh welsh
gone actually it's like okay stephen
please differentiate endos and well
that's south african there okay um i
will say what we're good at in the uk is
taking other ideas
and
or just taking other things periods
don't ask where the british museum got
all their stuff from that's
landing in the uk you heard of uh
devious licks that was a tick-tock trend
that uh the uk started back in uh back
in the 17th century or whatever
we are used to foreign food we have a
lot of it it's really good uh i said i'd
say you can get some pretty good
authentic of everything i guess yeah
that's that's because we don't have like
our own food that's very good so we just
have all the other countries food and
let them let them teach us how to make
it kind of like we don't kind of like
that in australia too
northern ireland and uh scotland are
beautiful you know wales is beautiful
they're there
have you seen the welsh flag
welsh flag castles we have castles lots
of castles we have a lot of castles
yeah really funny something
[Music]
um
like it still sucks
no we're still having [ __ ]
do you like theme actually like theme
parks oh yeah of course we have some
really good theme parks actually no
alton towers if you like if you like the
thrill rides okay here's the thing
because it's actually really good yeah
yeah so if you like the skateboard when
you go to the theme parks do you what do
you like the thrill rides or do you like
kind of like
okay then you'll love it okay
we have like
i'm gonna say we have some goddamn good
things
the smiler people so good people lost
their legs on it yeah
wait
okay it has the most loops in any single
uh
uh roller coaster i think yeah
unfortunately um unfortunately the best
rides are every time you go they're
probably going to be closed down for
some reason
as they always are
i can't remember that one ride in like
orton towers or thor park that was just
like the big oblivion
was it
oblivion can't remember
yeah okay so one thing i've never
understood is theme parks that i guess
are actual theme parks right because to
me theme parks are the thrill rights i
only care about the right i don't give a
[ __ ]
what kind of theme it is i don't give a
[ __ ] what the characters are basically
what i'm trying to say is i don't give a
[ __ ] about disneyland
you're really like you're really
throwing [ __ ] at disneyland right now
i'm going i'm going to six flags and go
to disneyland yeah yeah that sounds more
like yeah that's why i don't go to
different parks because i don't care
about threats i don't know what's wrong
with me but when i go to disneyland i
just feel this like creepy corporate
energy
of like
i'm trying to shove shove some kind of
happy childhood on me that i didn't have
it is kind of like happy pills isn't it
it is it feels like something out of
black mirror when i'm in disneyland
i i know it's you dude i go into this i
know it's nice no i hate things i'm not
saying everyone who goes to disneyland
is being like [ __ ] uh fed some kind
of fake i understand if you grew up with
it you like that that's that's totally
fair but for me when i feel i'm there i
get this like weird energy though i'm
just like
i just don't like theme parks in general
because i don't like thrall rides i
don't like roller coasters or anything
like that and it's the same thing it's
like to me the amusement parks are the
thrill rides and the roller coasters so
if you don't like throw rides on roller
coasters i'm not going to like amusement
park i'd rather go to like the movies i
think it's because i'm over the age of
12 i think as well i think that doesn't
well with disneyland yeah but i think
there's also
the amount of people i know that you've
just called out with that one live
basically every every female in japan
you're called out i know there are it's
a big thing a disney adult and you know
and there's a lot of disney
theme park youtubers yes did you know
that yes yes i know i know i know some
of them and like when i watch them yeah
it's like they're speaking in like a
foreign language to me i don't
understand well what do you mean because
they like they discuss like the optimal
route for like disneyland they all argue
about what the optimal route of
disneyland is and to me i'm like how
about how about you just all just get
turned up
[Music]
do you need to like plan everything well
yeah have you been okay what are the
what is the selling point of disneyland
i don't know i want to know
do you like it i think we're the only
ones
because you're the closest person to a
disney person that is true my girlfriend
is disneyland osmosis yeah you must know
kind of okay i i really i really i'm not
trying to insult you
who has a girlfriend who was a disney
fanatic
i can say that i think it's just like
the thing is though she like aki's not
the kind of person who goes to
disneyland by themselves because there's
a lot of people who do that
she's like i go that's crazy with other
people to like kind of show them around
if it's their first time or like you
know just to see like what's updated and
just like kind of enjoy the rides
obviously and enjoy like all the
activities that you can do with theme
parks and stuff what activities are
there what do you do
i don't know i don't go with them you
must have been with her once before i've
been in her once what did you do i
waited around until she was finished
with the ride well because the theme
park
and and ate a bunch of popcorn i don't
have a strong appreciation for the
characters and stuff i think that's what
it is because she's a kingdom hearts fan
so naturally she's going to like disney
[ __ ] as well okay what how do you feel
about they say the universal studios or
that kind of thing then well i i like
universal studios over
i felt like you were more chill
as well you know i kind of yeah it
didn't feel as intense i there's
something i don't know it is more chill
than disneyland i feel like i understand
that um
you know theme parks have like those
actors that are there
for like the kids yeah yeah yeah but
there's something just weird about it
when they like
for me i'm like whoa when when an actor
person tries to like speak to me
and i'm in character and i'm like
probably no i don't have a problem with
it i'm just like i'm like confused i'm
like
oh
what
i don't know why it freaks me out i
don't know it i don't know because it's
not really you want them to be in
character you don't want them to be
happy
kind of it's like it feels like they're
being held hostage when they're talking
but i know they like it i think it's a
british thing that i'm just like i can't
i'm like i shouldn't be happy i'm like
just talk to me like a normal person
i don't care if you're tarzan
it's like real life fee tubing yeah
right
i don't know i don't know i i really i
think i'm just
too british in some senses yeah i think
that's my excuse for a lot of things i
don't really wrap my i don't know why i
can't wrap my head around it what's
wrong with you i think it's because like
you know like the meta behind it like
you have to kind of be yeah i can't
immerse like you you have to immerse
yourself i think that's the best way to
enjoy like land or anything like that i
can immerse myself in like some like six
flags or or alton towers because all i
got to do is just get on that ride and
[ __ ] myself and have a good time but
that's the thing that's the biggest
difference right like disneyland is like
it sets itself up as like it's like
another world it's like another country
or like consonant you know it's like i
have no issues with this now i don't
people think i'm hating on disneyland i
just i i i can't get into it but like i
always wonder this right i'm like what
if right you made a theme park with all
of these new characters that no one knew
right absolutely brand new characters
and it was exactly like disneyland just
for characters you didn't know if you
went in there you would think it's
creepy because you don't know any of
these characters i guess because you're
like what is this like black mirror if
you went in there
like picture it you can literally just
picture it right it would be like a
black mirror-esque thing if you didn't
know any of the characters right i just
don't even think i'd be able to immerse
myself right
so i would just be like oh look there's
a kind of costume but like it's only not
weird unless you have character unless
you have characters you understand right
and you understand why they're doing
these things otherwise it's like why are
these people like dancing around and
pretending to be happy and
stuff it's just like strange you know
i think you're reading like way too deep
i don't know i think there's something
wrong with it
i don't like happy people
you know the uk is the uk the uk has
trained me well okay so what can i say i
do like
it's weird to me too i've never enjoyed
the seeing people in college you would
be freaked out if you went to a place
with no explanation with characters that
you didn't know just doing this stuff
and like it's all branded and all stuff
right it would be weird yeah
i don't know what do you think jason am
i crazy would it be weird what what a
new character like you went to a theme
park that's like a debut stream
i'm leaving i'm leaving have you ever
gone into a debut stream be like oh
that's weird
no because that's that's the start
that's the start of the story yeah well
you don't you don't go into a debut
stream commenting being like uh am i the
only one
connor come on i got it i got it okay a
theme park
with v tubers
with the rides
the roller coaster model
do you normally go to theme parks on
have you been to any of the theme parks
here in japan i want to go fuji japan
yeah i went to fuji fuji
foreign
that's the one i want to go to yeah yeah
and i went to disney world with my
friends disneyland with my friends too
um wait there's a disneyland and a
disneyland
in disneyland there's no disney world in
japan it's disney sea disneyland and
disney land yeah i went there
soon there will be disney sky as well
i love learning about i love learning
about disneyland i watch all like
defunct language videos it's pretty good
i love learning about disney i just
don't like i don't want to go to
disneyland i don't want to go disney i
don't know any good rides in the usj
oh yeah one if you like thrill rides
yeah one the the raptor one the jurassic
park one i don't go on for those
thorough rides dude you're going to
throw rides no i hate thrill rides what
i hate roller coasters
why why'd you hate roller coasters why
would i pay money to get scared it's not
scared it's a thrill it's adrenaline i
don't like that what
i don't like it you don't like
adrenaline no you don't feel adrenaline
when you do something exciting
to me that's not exciting that's just
scary
that's the only thing i like about
thrill parks i like when when you don't
feel like you're that's why i don't go
to amusement parks though we've
established this i don't go to amusement
park i thought it was just disneyland no
i all amusement parks i don't like
that's what i was saying when i went to
when i went to mario world right at usj
a while back that's that's like the
first time in like 10 plus years that i
went to an amusement park
because i just i don't find that
enjoyable at all i'd rather go to like
the movies
okay if everyone loves cereal rights
fuji
fuji i've heard is the best in japan
yeah it's all right yeah that's that's
what i want to go to
like usj maybe because you guys have
been really picking up nintendo worlds i
was going to call it mario world for a
second have you been to europe
yeah yeah once did you go have you been
recently with the mario thing
no
no i don't know that there's also the
key she just she doesn't know mario
she called super smash brothers melee
mario
you don't know anything about mario
no wait so i i wasn't allowed to play
games when i was little
you didn't play recently
um like any nintendo game at all no well
everyone like grew up with nintendo
right yeah mario and now i can't go in
like you can't grow up again
grow up again with it i'm too old
when did you start playing games and
watching anime then um that was when i
was in college oh my god so basically
when you started streaming then yeah
yeah yeah
okay so what what would like the first
games you played the very first one was
monster hunter oh okay yeah checks out
you went you went
you went in deep right from the get-go
jesus christ what's your favorite game
of all time of all time is yakuza series
oh
yeah hell yeah why why are we clapping
it's because it's a good game
it's winning an award or something
before i've never played it i played i
played yoga seven and zero it looks fun
yeah is is that like jojo do you have to
start it's basically jojo the game uh i
know it's basically jojo the game in a
lot of ways but i i heard from my
friends who like yakuza that it's best
to start with yakuza zero is that would
that be correct is that true is that
true um
well yakuza 0 i think is really the best
yeah
to start
i think yeah
one would be right right better there's
a remastered virgin
you don't condone skipping parts
[Music]
so you start with one
and then you go to
three
[Music]
wait so so what what would you say
is the best yoga game zero
i would say
my favorite yeah
is ishii
ishii do you know ishii
yeah i think that was the best
is that like is that like the kishibe
rohan of yakuza
but um before you play eachine you have
to play all the yakuza series to know
more about it so it's literally the kiss
mirror
i feel she's been explaining this oh no
no no that's fine it's fine it's the
imagine the yakuza series characters
within a period yeah oh okay okay
how would you feel if we started with
that game
um
like if i if i if i message you and said
i'm going to start uh my first yakuza
game and it's going to be yakuza ishin
what would you say to me well i won't
say anything but um
you won't understand it right because
all the characters that
that's on the eachine yeah it's the
character they used to be on the other
series so
that makes sense okay it's gonna be hard
to understand the characters right if
you start from isian it really makes it
see that's how we felt when you
explained that
because like a bunch of the side
characters just turn up in that one yeah
yeah like josuke turns up
because i think i think zero is supposed
to be like a prequel to one
so you can technically start with zero
but it would make more sense if you
played one first yeah
the mechanics because zero came out
after one my brain was already hurting
yeah i'm not doing this
every jojo fan is like yes i understand
completely
so before we wrap things up is there
anything you want to say to your viewers
or fans or our viewers and fans ah of
course i need to tell them i love you
thank you
i love you guys you can't say that after
you do [ __ ] on us did i
yes you did there is now an entire
highlights clip
off the case and [ __ ] on the youtube
can't believe this
that's okay it's you're basically uk if
you do that you're basically british
yeah
you're you're an honorary breed now
because you shouldn't i thought the
french could [ __ ] the uk as hard as uh
what just happened right now but uh
i guess caisson just proved us wrong
right
where can people find uk son
uh me anywhere in on youtube on um i
stream on youtube mostly on youtube but
i stream on mildum it's a platform you
can
uh mostly use on your phone it's a
japanese platform oh okay
i've never heard of that platform
we'll have all these links in the
description of course yes where else
twitter oh and twitter twitter yeah uh
kate's on on air yeah i'm there please
find me you're gonna be way more
aggressive about plugging yeah you gotta
get into it okay you're really like
[ __ ] here's where you go smack that
link in the description i'm live every
goddamned week like that yeah
i'm not like that
how how often do you stream i don't
think we ask that but uh how often do
you stream when compete when can viewers
find you live mostly um i stream every
day like once or twice
i'm a full-time streamer
yeah people are just a different
youtuber you know people who work
full-time they take weekends off right
i don't yeah i don't either i'm not
saying
you know one week has seven days yeah
and some people decide to only work
five days
um japanese people don't
he's just destroying like every culture
right now
what are you so much for joining us
australia what do you think about
strength do you like australia oh yeah
of course let's [ __ ] yes
what do you like about australia
oh i think they like
they're fun people they're like hell
yeah we all dog let's go
i thought british people didn't exist
i am i am a happy boy you know what you
do the [ __ ] outro all right let's do
that i don't want to be on this podcast
yeah all right if you enjoyed this show
make sure to follow us on patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on spotify and if you
uh send us a spotify sentence on the
subreddit if you hate our face listen to
us on spotify and of course go check out
caisson all the links down in the
description below but thanks for coming
casa thank you for having me today hell
yeah okay so and on this podcast we're
meant to clown on americans not not the
brits
i can't believe i don't exist
all the americans are like first time
but now you know is this how the
americans feel [ __ ] man [ __ ]
i'm really humbly
all right have a good one guys see you
next time
[Music]
you